außerhalb mal der reihe
so komplett random
wobei das das erweckt jetzt ja fast den anschein als hätte ich regelmäßige streamzeiten oder sowas in der richtung
Was natürlich nicht der fall ist
so funktioniert das hier guck mal unity media scheint zu tun also wo doch wo doch vorne scheint alles zu gehen
um die leute mal ein bisschen zu triggern
ich finde es immer geil wie viele leute darauf anspringen
Warum haben wir dann ein schachvideo
Warum habe ich den excellent exquisite big brain schachvideo auf dem desktop
Richtige hacker mann einfach da geht sonst nix
Schrieben stell es am donnersnacht ja ich weiß ich weiß ich sage komplett außerhalb der reihe ne
komplett außerhalb der reihe
Komm wir gucken uns mal ein bisschen aquarium an
Die leute
Den corona video war nice aber das ist schön wenn es gefallen habt ihr alle schon mal neues youtube video gesehen
Ich habe ja tatsächlich ein neues video klaren und ich lade noch zwei andere hoch ich laden einmal noch ein video hoch über boomer im homeoffice
Aller die letzten tage ihr könnt euch sich vorstellen
Du hast oh mein moment ich sehe es gerade ich muss meinen pp-gabort wieder anschmeißen
Sonst haben wir die fragen vergesst sonst über sehe ich die fragen wieder wo ist es da ist es hier pp-gabort
zack wenn ich aquarium
so
Ach du hast das mich
Konnte ich nicht richtig zu
Der youtube streak da weiß ich nicht ob die youtube streaks anfängt
Ich muss gerade mal chat ich sehe euch gerade nicht ich refresche nämlich gerade mal den chat so
Jetzt sehe ich euch wieder kommt gar nicht auf
Mein zauber ist weg
Ich weiß nicht was er für schmerzen hat aber gut jetzt müssen wir mal gucken jetzt muss man kurz bei windows überprüfen ob das ob das sound noch richtig funktioniert weil manchmal spackt er ja rum aus nicht näher erkennbaren gründen
Da müssen wir mal gucken ob das sound noch richtig funktioniert weil manchmal spackt er ja rum aus nicht näher erkennbaren gründen
Da müssen wir uns nämlich mal gucken das sound funktioniert achtung dildim dildim
Exzellent funktioniert yes und der hier der hier sollte knistern der sollte nicht funktionieren aber wenn das so ist dann ist alles richtig eingestellt
Ja ja richtig der knistert also lassen wir den aus sehr gut das sound ist richtig funktioniert also mein lautstärke ist auch okay in sehr schön das komme ich mal gleich da
Gleich da eiken eiken weg weil ich bin ich bin ja schon da
Habt ihr habt ihr mal neues video geguckt wollen wir mal neues video na komm wir können später noch mal neues video zusammenfassen
Ja ihr glaubt nicht was ihr beim thema homeoffice leute ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen ich hab das gefühl
Die hälfte der leute hat noch nie in ihrem leben voice chat verwendet und man darf jetzt nicht vergessen
Da sind leute die arbeiten in der IT und die verdienen ihr geld mit IT
Das darf man nicht vergessen die stellen sich alle an und in jeder besprechung wie gesagt wir haben ja Microsoft Teams mittlerweile
Und in jeder besprechung und in jeder besprechung hast du irgendeinen typ der es nicht schafft push to talk zu machen oder Teams kann ja kein push to talk Teams kann ja kein push to talk
Teams kann ja nur manuell muten manuell anmuten was im endeffekt sowas wie push to talk ist
In jeder besprechung hast du da fünf leute wenn es genug sind die im hintergrund handy klingeln haben die dann irgendwelche
Tastatur geile geile Hackermans machen auf der Tastatur im hintergrund die kriegen es alle nicht gebacken ich weiß gar nicht was daran so schwer ist
Danke schön für die drei monate primes
Oh leute soll ich euch mal ein video zeigen ist das ihr bar oder
Das ist das ist für die für die weeps im chat das ist was das gefällt euch
Das kann ich euch gleich sagen dass das das findet ihr super
Der martin abonniert acht monate huge sub dankeschön big fadrig big primes big big big primes big primes sub
Richtig echter gar kein prime richtig echter und zwar das wurde mir letztens das wurde passt mal auf das wurde wo habe ich denn das video
Ich habe mir das ich habe mir das extra extra kopiert weil ich mir gedacht habe chat das das muss ich
Das muss ich dem chat zeigen der chat freut sich oder scam train leute
So geier warum ist mein sound wieder weg mein sound ist wieder weg
Ich gucke da schon gar nicht mehr rein kurz mal kurz inkognito nicht dass wir noch mehr videos dieser art empfohlen
Bekommen wir gucken uns das jetzt auch nicht an ich dachte mir nur dass das dass das hier den den den anime fans garantiert gefällt
Im chat und zwar video titel ist mal wenn du schon nachgucken wie video titel ist dass ich das ihr gleich wisst worauf wir euch
Warum geht immer mein sound aus heute geht er bei euch auch aus oder hört ihr mich weiter und nur ich höre mich selbst nicht
Wtf mein sound geht die ganze landung aus was ist denn das man hört mich ok ich glaube ich muss mal die soundkarte rein
Ziehen wieder rein stecken also der video titel ist ich sage nichts guckt euch mal an die gucken wir uns nicht an ich sage nur was es nicht alles gibt
Alter bcf was ist das corona chart infektio wtf ich weiß nicht ey das hat übelst oh oh sexually ach du scheiße
Sexually infektio bockartossala
Manchmal verstehe ich die welt nicht mehr was ist denn da schon wieder los
Das wär was für ein sebaro eindeutig
Madsufini98 vier monate dankeschön
Homeoffice läuft super
Da haben wir noch am start hier der felix ist am start sieben monate
Ich mach mal kurz meine soundkarte raus und wieder rein
Irgendwie irgendwie spackt das gerade über usb rum
So sollte eigentlich klar alles funktionieren hoffe ich mal
Btf die soundkarte ist nicht mehr richtig angegangen
Das ist eine 600 euro soundkarte die solltet man nicht abkacken was soll das
Btf was ist jetzt wo unity media funktioniert spackt die soundkarte rum
Ich glaube es kommt sich hier vor als wäre es sabotiert laufen
Die kirby musik ist mir doch ein bisschen zu entspannend muss ich ehrlich sagen
Aber dann nicht noch irgendwas anderes
Bisschen wupp wupp im zweifelsfall hauptsache hauptsache bisschen bisschen hintergrund
Hintergrundgeräusch am start
So dann hab ich dann hab ich noch mal eine frage an euch chat
Und zwar ich hab schon auf twitter gefragt aber so 100 prozentig schlau bin ich daraus nicht gewonnen
Aber ich weiß ja dass hier der chat der ist ja hier absolut massive IQ
Ich hab hier aktuell in meinem rechner folgenden arbeitsspeicher
Hast du dich schon die reviews zur half life alex angucken
Ja soll der beste VR shooter ever sein
Mein problem ist ich würd's mir gerne holen
Aber ich hab kein bock drauf mir nur einen VR headset zu holen
Einfach für ein game und danach vergammelts
Ich hab sogar einen guides als link
Also guck mal leute ich hab jetzt aktuell wie viele
Doch VR shooter gibt sogar ein paar
Nicht dass ich mir zu namen einfallen würde aber ich weiß dass es ein paar gibt
Also mir geht's nicht dass der rgb hat
Das da ist der ram das ist irgendwie 3200mhz takt
Wobei das ist DDR das ist ja nur fake takt im endeffekt
Und das sind hier die zugriffszeiten
Jetzt mal die frage an den huge big brain chat
Ich hab ja schon auf twitter gefragt und twitter war so
War der meinungen das funktioniert wohl ganz gut
Lohnt sich das für ein ryzen system
Ich mein der ram ist nicht schlecht
Der ram ist zack der ist ziemlich schnell
Ich mein die alternative wäre 3600
Von den zugriffszeiten ist das ziemlich geschwind
Also im bereich wo man sich den kram noch gut leisten kann
Und dass es nicht extrem teuer wird
Weil ich überleg mir doch grad ob ich mir nicht doch noch jetzt ein ryzen system hole
Ich hab ja letztes jahr schon überlegt
Aber irgendwie ich hätte gerne einfach 12 oder 16 kerne
Ja ne ich hab mir aber kein ryzen gekauft
Weil ich damals gesagt hab mir reicht das ganze
So und ich hab nämlich mittlerweile 32g
Also ich hab hier drinne ich hab hier 16
Und ich hab aber noch ne packung hier liegen mit dem gleichen ram noch mal 16
Ich hab mir jetzt eigentlich so viel memory belegt
Es ist nichts auf
Okay windows alles klar
Es läuft ne vm in der nix läuft
Und browser
Einfach mal 12g belegt
Viele chromium tabs
Oh ja 6 stück wahnsinn
Zeig mal im taskmanager ja lass mal gucken
Ah
Nichts belegt so viel ram
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach
Ram der mal angefordert wurde
Und noch nicht explizit wieder freigegeben ist
Sondern sobald man ihn braucht wieder benutzt werden kann
Also das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so wild
So
Memory
Net viel oder
Ja
Ich mein es ist ein bisschen fragwürdig warum
Chrome überhaupt 16 mal 16 threads laufen hat
Und 1 gigabyte ram braucht für 6 tabs
Aber da hab ich mich ja schon dran gewöhnt mittlerweile
Du hattest heute spotify bei 23g
Ja es leben echt nicht
Es leben elektron anwendung
Beziehungsweise reine browser anwendung
Beste
Vielleicht kann ich den ram auch ein bisschen
Übertanken das ist eigentlich ne gute idee
User 32 dll
Woll ich mal gucken
Aber ich hol mir wenn schon hol ich mir
Ne ne
Das ist so für mich
Die beste kombi
Das ding hat ordentlich
Und eine sache hab ich noch nicht so ganz kapiert
Spotify ist elektron wahrscheinlich
Im zweifelsfall ist spotify elektron
Das ganze browser
Das sind alles browser anwendungen
So
Eine sache hab ich noch nicht ganz gecheckt
Was ryzen angeht
Und übertakt und sowas
Man kann ja wohl, wobei ich hab es schon gecheckt
Aber ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher ob das
Ob das 100 prozentig stimmt
So
Nämlich man kann
Ryzen also das ding übertaktet sich von haus aus
Wie alle anderen halbwegs modernen cpu
Also sprich wenn man nur einen kern braucht
Geht das bis auf 4,7 gigahertz hoch
Wobei der bauer hat ja mal ein video
gemacht dass die 4,7
Seltenst erreicht werden und meistens
So ein 4,5 oder sowas
Was man jetzt machen kann ist
Man kann die ding ja übertakten
So quasi diese all core
All core
Enhancement also sprich dass man
Alle kerne auf den takt
Setzt damit verliert man halt
Dieses dynamische sich selbst übertakten
Ähm
Oder das ist besser gesagt das ist die frage
Verliert man damit das dynamische
Selbst übertakten
Spotify ist
Q2webview
Ja das ist ja auch nicht viel besser als elektrone
Das ist im prinzip auch chrome mittlerweile
Die q2web engine ist
Das ist äh es ist auch ein chrome
So und die frage ist jetzt nur entweder habe ich sie
Richtig kapiert oder es lohnt sich wirklich nicht
Weil was man machen kann ist
Das ding übertaktet sich ja selbst
Je nach je nach äh auslastung
Bis auf 4,7 besser gesagt 4,5
Weil die 4,7 reines marketing
Gelaber sind von amd
Wenn man jetzt all core übertaktung
Macht dann kann man die eben
Nicht auf 4,5
4,7 setzen sondern
Sagen wir mal so vielleicht
Vielleicht mit viel glück auf 4,4
Wahrscheinlich eher 4,3
So und das heißt auch im endeffekt wenn ich das jetzt richtig
Verstanden habe
All core übertaktend beim ryzen
Bringt nur was
Wenn ich permanent
Multicore
Brutalst multicore workload habe
Den ich mit 16 kern garantiert nicht habe
Oder
Weil ansonsten fahre ich wahrscheinlich
Besser wenn er sich dynamisch
Selbst hochtaktet auf
Eventuell bis zu 4,7
Das habe ich richtig verstanden
Das ist ja schon mal gut
Ja ich habe ja durch den chat
Mittlerweile auch massive IQ
So viele leute die schon gesubbt haben
Das ist der platz da kommt
So ist das also
Gut dann habe ich das richtig verstanden dann ist es total
Bescheuert
So und dann brauche ich noch eine
Andere sache
Die ganzen ultratorren boards
Lohnen doch überhaupt nicht oder
Was ich mir jetzt rausgesucht habe ist
Was z
Heiß die z 470
Nee oh Gott wie heiß die Dinger
Ich kann mir den kram nicht mehr
Was x470
Ah ja
Das da
Ich glaube
Nee
Ach du kacke kann man das nicht merken zumindest
Das das
Das habe ich mir als mainboard rausgesucht
Aber nicht das x500
Hier das da xx
Das das das da das da das
So
Und das hat
Mir eigentlich preisleistungsmäßig
Ganz gut gefallen was ist da jetzt der
Unterschied zwischen ultimate nicht ultimate
Das kostet 50
Euro mehr brauchen wir nicht
PC express 4.5 ganz ehrlich
Geht mir voll am arsch vorbei
So das fand ich
Das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut das ist nicht so
Total übertrieben das board
Mit zeug was du eh nicht
Brauchst mit 5 Netzwerkadapter
Mit 10g mit sonst was ich mach
10g 10g adapter
Rein
Wupp wupp der moni
3 monate big brain
Und das was da drinnen war macht eigentlich
Einen ganz guten Eindruck hier kommt die grafikkarte
Rein hier kommt
Die warte mal
Ist das ein einfach oder ist das ein vierfach
Das ist ein einfach
Hier kommt die grafikkarte rein
Hier kommt die
Netzwerkkarte rein die 10g
Und was anderes
Brauche ich glaube ich eh nicht
So fand alles top passt ja wunderbar
Ramriegel flop flop flop 32g
Ryzen
Gut ist fertig
Gehäuse habe ich
Netzteil habe ich
Ja dann
Dann werde ich es auch eigentlich so machen ja
Zumal das board sogar relativ
relativ günstig naja ne
Was macht Intel
Eigentlich gerade
Kommt da
1080ti
Ja aber ich übertakte
Ja nichts
Dann ist doch die Stromversorgung jetzt für mich nicht so wild oder
Wozu
Oh
Echt ist das hat das eine on board
10g karte wenn das eine on board 10g karte
Hat dann wird sich sogar lohnen
Wo stehts denn hier
Ah
Ach ja
Ich mein
Das ist zwar Kupfer
Das ist zwar eine Kupfer Netzwerkkarte
Es geht gerade aktuell um gar nichts bestimmtes
Bimmerboy sondern einfach nur
Was ich mit dem was ich mit dem mainboard kaufen soll
Normalerweise habe ich ja ein bisschen
Gewinstes Ziel was ich im stream
Machen will aber heute habe ich mir gedacht
Wir machen einfach das was wir sonntags auch machen
Wir schwätzen ein bisschen gucken uns ein bisschen
YouTube Zeug an und ich muss ja eh in
Eineinhalb Stunden schon wieder auf
Das war eher so eine spontane Geschichte
Das ist eigentlich relativ gut
Wieso warst du eigentlich inaktiv
Auf YouTube weil mir
Weil YouTube eine Kackplattform geworden ist
Es laufen auf YouTube so viele
Vollspasten mittlerweile rum dass ich immer
Anfälle kriege wenn ich YouTube aufmache
Deutschland YouTube international auch
Aber Deutschland YouTube
Sonders wenn ich Deutschland
YouTube aufmache die Startseite
Wir simulieren das mal kurz
YouTube Deutschland
So was haben wir hier
Ja den kann man sich angucken
Der ist cool
Der ist mir sogar schon mal auf dem Weg zum Südbahnhof
Auf dem Weg gelaufen
Was trending
Trending müssen wir gucken
So Familie entführt
Dean greift an
Ah ja
Super geile Trends
Was haben wir als nächstes
Okay ich wusste gar nicht
Dass sie die Nintendo Direct haben
Tränen in den Augen
Sarah Lombardi singt Pietros neuen Song
Meine Güte
Bundesliga Challenge
JP Performance
Ich habe einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit
Guckt den ganzen Tag
Wenn er nichts zu tun hat
Guckt er diese Autotuning
Dinge Ben und Lea
Küssen sich
Ich weiß nicht mal wer Ben und Lea
Ist
Antoni versteckt sich im Wald
Gegen
Das ist doch der
Das ist der Integrationstest
Mann könnt ihr euch
Noch an dieses Integrationstest Video
Erinnern was halt voll gefakt war wo damals
Alle gedacht haben das wäre das wäre
Das wäre legit
Angelo Merte
Genau
Angelo Merte genau der ist das
So dann haben wir Semmel versus Brötchen
Was einfach mal 834k aufruft
Krass Schule
Da kommt einmal
Der Lash an Start mit
einer ganzen Folge
Und es ist noch schlimmer
Bei mir die Empfehlungen
Auf Youtube sind noch schlimmer als das was wir jetzt hier sehen
10 Minuten zum Sixpack
Eats
Das mache ich das mache ich auch
Auf gehts
Komm zeig mal her
Ich kann die
Ne kann ich mir nicht angucken
Tut mir leid Leute kann ich mir nicht angucken
Und bei mir ist die Empfehlung
Noch schlimmer
Weil ich bin ja auf Youtube
Quasi immer im Gaming Bereich unterwegs
Und der schlägt mir permanent
Gaming
Und funny German
Pranks
Ich kann mir das nicht mehr angucken
Das heißt was ich mittlerweile mache ist
Ich benutze Youtube
Für Videos über
Firefox
Ich benutze
Ich gehe nicht auf Youtube
Ich benutze ansonsten Youtube
Immer über Chrome mit einem zweiten Account
Dass ich keine scheiß Empfehlung kriege
Da kriege ich so gut wie keine deutschen Videos als Empfehlung
Und auch nur das was ich abonniert habe
Was mir gefällt und das halte ich aus
Rest kann ich
Ertrage ich nicht
Also falls ihr
Mein neues Video noch nicht geguckt habt
Gibt es Leute die mein neues Video noch nicht geguckt haben
Es haben
Es haben manche geschrieben
Es wirkt für sie wie ein Comedy Programm
War jetzt nicht unbedingt
Die Absicht
Ich habe mir zur Abwechslung einfach nur ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben
Ja
Aber vorher müssen wir mal gucken
Ob ich Fragen übersehen habe
Guck mal hier
Fragen Tool
Ich will mir aktuell nichts neues kaufen
Hab noch einen E7
Warte noch bis neue Grafiker an CPUs kommen
Was macht denn Intel so?
Kommt von Intel demnächst was gescheites
Streaming Setup
Mein Streaming Setup ist nicht so
Spektakulär
Ich habe hier meinen einen Rechner
Wo ich von streame und was ihr jetzt seht
Ich habe einen Rechner hier für Stream Vorschau
Also da gibt es nichts großartiges zu sagen
Von Intel kommt was aber nichts gescheites
Okay
Ich meine Intel hat ja die Chance
Ich glaube nicht dass sie schaffen jetzt direkt
Architektur mäßig
Zu AMD direkt wieder aufzuschließen
Das glaube ich nicht, aber
Es ist ja nicht so als wäre Intel hoffnungslos hinten dran
Also da ist ja jetzt nicht so
Da ist ja im normalen
Im normalen Desktop Segment jetzt nicht irgendwie
Welten zwischen Intel und AMD
In der Vergangenheit war es halt einfach so
Dass AMD das bessere Angebot hatte
Aber wenn Intel jetzt den Kram
Einfach billiger macht
Wenn Intel den Kram billiger macht
Dann gibt es keinen Grund
Warum man nicht Intel kaufen sollte
Was für eine Klasse
Ich spiele gerade relativ wenig per Sofx
Weil ich nie so richtig reingekommen bin, weiß ich auch nicht
Äh das sind noch Fragen vom letzten Mal
Kann das sein?
Das sind die Fragen vom Sonntag
Macht eigentlich Stadia so
Abkacken wahrscheinlich
Also
Welche Neuerungen kommen
Das können wir uns mal angucken
Da bin ich gespannt, habe ich schon mal aufgemacht
Ob der das ein bisschen besser erklären kann
Als dieser komische Block Eintrag das letzte Mal
Beim letzten Mal hast du auch die Fragen vergessen
Ja aber die waren im Bezug auf den letzten Stream
Und ich habe keine Ahnung mehr
Was ist mit den los?
Wir gucken uns mal den Anfang an ob das irgendwie interessant ist
Wenn nicht, skippen wir das einfach
Das Microsoft Magazine
Hallo Leute, herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem neuen Video hier auf Windows Area
Und es freut mich, dass du eingeschaltet hast
Und schon wieder ist ein halbes Jahr vergangen
Was bedeutet das?
Es ist Zeit für ein neues Video
Da hat er sich an, das muss er gleich loslachen
Und schon wieder ist ein halbes Jahr vergangen
Heute stelle ich euch
Windows 10 Version 2004 format
Oder einfach das April 2020 Update
Falls ihr dich jetzt jemand fragt
Wieso die Versionsnummer 2004 lautet
Oder man kann´s auch 2004 aussprechen
Weil
Es Microsoft ist
Und sie ihre eigenen Sachen nicht einhalten
Ich meine das ist 2020 04
Ist nicht 20 April
Nein nein durch das事
Wie bitte, well.
Es ist nicht 20. April. Nein, nein, es ist 2020 April, aber Microsoft, das ergibt mittlerweile keinen großartigen Sinn mehr.
Ich mein diesmal schaffen sie es vielleicht, aber im letzten Mal haben sie es nicht, haben sie es selbst nicht geschafft einzuhalten.
Das ist die gleiche, die gleiche Ubuntu, die Ubuntu-Taktik.
Und wenn man mag, die Versionsnummer setzt sich einmal aus der Hand von Cortana in Deutschland zurzeit nicht verfügbar. Das hat jetzt folgenden Hintergrund.
Microsoft möchte Cortana umfokussieren.
Das ist mir scheißegal, juckt mich nicht.
Cortana.
Ah, die Windaussuche, die nicht richtig funktioniert, ja, schön, schön.
Angeblich ist die Windaussuche jetzt neu und die Windaussuche, das habe ich im Vorfeld schon gelesen, die Windaussuche ist neu und funktioniert jetzt viel besser als vorher.
Wobei ich mir dann immer denke, wenn ich im Zweifelsfall, wenn ich wirklich unter Windows was suchen will, nehme ich einfach Grab.
Ist zwar kein Windows eigenes Tool oder Find, ja, Find und Grab und gut ist.
Erstmal mit der Suchindizierung, dazu begehe ich mich nicht einfach. Ah, das habe ich schon gelesen, das ist neu, angeblich funktioniert die Suche jetzt gut.
CMDR, klick los.
Okay, der ist immer noch bei der Suche. Let's go. Kein Wunder, dass das Video 38 Minuten geht.
Wir konnten einfach nur die ersten 10 Minuten easy skippen, weil nichts da war. Oh, das Spielmodus.
Das wäre nicht mehr indexiert, das ist vor allem sehr gut. Auch endlich, wenn ein PC Problem helfen muss und ihr merkt, sein PC ist langsam, dann könnt ihr einfach hier gucken, ist sein Windows jetzt auf einer schnellen SSD festgestellt oder auf einer alten langsamen HDD festgestellt.
Und jetzt kommt wirklich meine Lieblingsneuerung und ich habe lange darauf gewartet und ich bin selber überrascht, dass sie in Windows integriert wurde, hier im Task Manager.
Das hört schon gleich viel, viel besser an, oder? Und zwar eine Temperaturanzeige für die GPU.
Die sieht man einmal hier in der Schnellübersicht, 5% Auslastung, 50 Grad und auch hier einmal in der Detailübersicht.
Porkers! Porkers! Oh mein Gott, wir können im Task Manager die GPU Temperatur anzeigen lassen.
Ich muss gerade mal was nachgucken. Ich will mal kurz wissen, wie weit mein Server ist.
Und zwar, ich habe doch vor, im letzten Stream erzählt, dass ich gerade OpenStreetMaps, OpenStreetMaps kann man das kompilieren nennen, dass ich gerade OpenStreetMaps, wie nennt man das, extrahiere.
Ich will mir einen OpenStreetMaps Server bauen, für unser Routenplanungs-Tool da. Und, ähm...
Ich muss mal gucken, wie weit der ist. Wie weit ist er denn? Er ist immer noch nicht fertig.
WTF. Der läuft seit 5 Tagen oder so. Das Ding hat 16 Kerne. Na ok, 8 mit Hyper-Threading. Die Kiste hat 8 Kerne.
24G RAM, 100G Swap auf eine SSD. Warum braucht das so lange? Der macht hier auch gar nichts.
Kalua. Warum braucht das so lange? Ich habe seit 2 Tagen nicht mehr draufge... Nee, nee, der hat sich nicht aufgehangen. Der ist hier 10, 20, 30, 40. Ich habe vor 2 Tagen draufgeguckt, da hat er noch was anderes gemacht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er sich aufgehangen hat. Guck, der macht auch hier was. Ok, ich bin wieder weg. Also hier, ich logg mich wieder aus. So, gucken wir uns hier über den Task Manager weiter an.
So, und das war es auch schon mit dem Task Manager. Hab ich eigentlich schon erwähnt, dass dieses Update wirklich kurz ist. Also, ich glaube die Entwicklungszeit war...
Ja, aber 38 Minuten kann man trotzdem mitfallen....zirka 9 Monate und wir haben wirklich sehr, sehr wenig, aber auch komplett neue... Oh, was ist das?
Oh, Leute, das wollten wir uns ja auch nochmal angucken im Stream. Den Windows 10 X Emulator. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns das wirklich angucken sollen, weil das ist ja das neue...
...das zukünftige Windows 10, was für Tablets und Gedöns gedacht ist, wo die Leute jetzt Schiss haben, dass es irgendwann auch auf den Desktop kommt.
Mich erinnert das ja ein bisschen an Windows 8 mit Kacheln, wenn ich ehrlich bin, das Ding. Jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, das wollte das wie gesagt. Ich habe auch eine Liste gemacht mit Themen für die nächsten Streams. Die gucken wir uns gleich nochmal an, ob euch noch ein paar Sachen auffallen.
Äh, gab noch ein Kommentar im Chat. Gibt es eigentlich nochmal eine aktualisierte Version des Memetools, die auch für nicht Progas benutzbar ist?
Oh ja, ich hoffe irgendwann schon, ja. Ich hoffe schon. Aber das, was ich aktuell zusammengebaut habe, das kann ich nicht releasen. Das ist für den Arsch.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin hier echt fehl am Platz, wenn man keine Ahnung von PCs hat. Ich bin nur wegen der Emotes hier. Das hört jetzt auch schon aus wie für jeden.
Vielleicht wirst du noch irgendwann zum echten Hacker-Man.
Das neue System, dazu habe ich auch ein Video gemacht, das findet ihr jetzt oben rechts, wo ich einmal eine Tour mache, durch eine frühe Version von dem System.
Damit zuviel Leute, die ihr könnt, die verrückt ist. So wie es halt bei Windows 10 ist.
Okay, was gibt es sonst noch?
Das ist halt so. Machen wir dann weiter mit dem Emoji-Panel. Öffnet sich natürlich jetzt fantastischerweise unten rechts, aber ich kann ja ranzoomen.
Äh.
Muss ich in jedem Video immer erwähnen, weil das Wissen halt...
Moment, das Emoji-Panel. Wie macht man das Emoji-Panel aktuell überhaupt auf?
Also mein Emoji-Panel funktioniert aktuell so. Get Emoji, ich gehe auf die Seite und kopiere mir das Emoji raus, was ich brauche.
Windows plus Punkt.
Ah, excellent.
Exquisite Emoji. Kann man da drin suchen?
Smile. Moment, kann man nicht suchen?
Doch.
Hä?
What the fuck?
What?
Ich...
Hä?
Wie suche ich da drin?
Sehe ich das richtig, dass die anwenden, dass das kaputt ist?
Excellent.
Einfach tippen.
Okay. Smile. Ich tippe.
Was ist das? Ist das Scheiß wirklich kaputt?
Meine Güte, ey.
Kack Software. Ernsthaft, ey.
Guck mal hier, das zeigt auch so komische Sonderzeichen an.
Geh mal in eine Textbox.
Okay, ich bin in einer Textbox. Punkt.
So, Test.
Ah.
Ah, ex. Jetzt bin ich einfach nur zu dumm für so was.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt quasi sagen...
Jetzt kann ich sagen, Smile.
Was hat er hier eigentlich durchgestrichen?
Dann kann man hier das Boomer Emoji verwenden.
Ja, warum nicht? Warum nicht?
Wenn man es braucht.
Weiter.
Leider wirklich sehr wenig Leute. Ihr könnt dieses Emoji-Panel mit der Tassenkombination wissen.
Und hier wurden neue hinzugefügt. Das geht jetzt nach Emoji 12 Standard.
Ach.
Haben die es jetzt auch schon geschafft bei Microsoft?
Ist Unicode 12 nicht schon ein Jahr alt oder so?
Ja, es ist genau ein Jahr alt.
Gut, Microsoft braucht da ein bisschen für. Kann man ja verstehen.
Die haben zu wenig Geld dafür, ein paar Emojis zu machen. Das geht nicht.
Da habe ich mein Leben lang drauf gewartet.
Das sind die Einstellungen mit den Smileys.
Das klingt jetzt unvorbereitet.
Andere Sachen drinnen fange ich einmal an mit einer Sache, die ich euch unglaublich gerne zeigen.
Oh, es geht. Oh mein Gott, es geht.
Okay, das klingt jetzt unvorbereitet.
Oh mein Gott.
Aber ich kann euch wirklich versprechen. Ihr könnt es mir glauben.
Diese Liste war die ganze Zeit weiß.
Ich habe diese Installation seit einer Woche. Seit einer Woche möchte ich dieses Video machen.
Ich kam bis jetzt noch nicht dazu.
Diese Liste war die ganze Zeit leer und ich wusste nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ich habe sogar meinen privaten PC aktualisiert und die Liste war ebenfalls leer.
Aber jetzt ist sie persönlich da.
Ich finde es ja geil, wie man so ausrasten kann, deswegen.
Ich finde es schöner, wenn man sich über sowas freut.
Ich freue mich auch oftmals über kleine Sachen.
Ich bin gerade wirklich dankbar. Ich weiß nicht, wieso sie da ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Update heute Morgen das gepikst hat oder ob es etwas gebracht hat,
dass sich das in den Feedback abgeschrieben hat.
Der hat gehacksort.
Ich bin gerade wirklich dankbar.
Denen kann ich euch jetzt zeigen.
Alte Funktionen wurden als optionale Features ausgelagert.
Was sind optionale Features?
Erstmal zur Verständlichkeit.
Paint!
In Windows sind Sachen integriert.
Paint ist jetzt ein optionales Feature.
Paintchamp.
Hier öffne ich mein Startmenü, gehe zu Zubehör und hier habe ich halt die Standardsachen.
Ich meine, ich habe Editor, Paint, Snipping Tool, Windows Media Player.
Das kennt man halt.
Paint ist das wichtigste unter Windows.
Man hat die Möglichkeit, schon seit Langem diese Features zu deaktivieren und zu aktivieren.
Das alte Menü sah halt so aus.
Und hier habe ich sogar ein paar erweiterte Features.
Also hier kann ich Internet Explorer deaktivieren und dafür kann ich beispielsweise...
Ja, es ist übrigens geil, dass es immer noch doppelte Menüs gibt.
Jetzt Dinge wie die Druckverwaltungskonsole deinstallieren oder Editor.
Editor natürlich, das kennt jeder.
Man kann Notepad deinstallieren.
Das geht aber nicht.
Man kann doch nicht einfach Notepad deinstallieren.
Kann ich erstmalig deinstallieren.
Internet Explorer habe ich schon deinstalliert.
Die Mathematikerkennung war glaube ich schon mal im letzten Update dabei.
Aber Microsoft Paint ist jetzt wirklich neu.
Das heißt, falls jemand von euch nur Paint 3D nutzt, was übrigens ein richtig cooles Programm ist...
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe nicht einmal Paint 3D verwendet bisher.
Ich verwende für so kurze Screenshots Sachen.
Wenn ich einen Screenshot gemacht habe, mache ich immer Paint auf, füge den ein,
mache dann irgendwie so und speicher den.
Für alles andere nehme ich Affinity Designer oder Affinity Photo.
Paint 3D ausprobieren statt dem alten Paint.
Es ist die Frage, ob auch Candy Crush deinstallieren kann.
Wer sagt, ich benutze weder Paint 3D noch das alte Paint.
Ich habe Motherfucking GIMP.
Für den ist das auch okay.
Einfach mit Paint und so weiter.
Auch die PowerShell Ease.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin Linux und Open Source Fan.
Aber GIMP kommt mir wirklich nicht in die Tüte oder nicht auf den Rechner drauf.
Das alte Wordpad, wieso auch immer das existiert, ist auch deinstallierbar.
Das Snipping Tool ist für Noobs.
Allgemein hat Microsoft in der neuen Feature-Liste das Design überarbeitet.
Ich kann jetzt hier nach Features suchen.
GIMP ist nicht böse.
Ich komme mit GIMP unter Bedienung überhaupt nicht zurecht.
Ich kann hier mehrere anwählen.
Oh mein Gott, man kann eine Liste durchsuchen.
Porgers.
Das ist wirklich eine sehr schöne Neuerung.
Was steht als nächstes auf meiner Liste?
Man darf nicht vergessen, wer jetzt denkt, warum flippt das so aus.
Ich habe es auf 1,25 Speed.
Normalerweise flippt das nicht ganz so aus.
Content und Anwälte Option.
Das ist eine Neuerung.
Hallo, Anmeldung für Microsoft-Konten erforderlich.
Wow, das ist eine sehr gute Übersetzung.
Zum Glück bin ich ja da und ich kann es euch erklären.
Falls ihr euch in Windows mit eurem Microsoft-Konto eingeloggt habt...
Nein.
Das mache ich auch nicht.
Richtig Boomer-Antwort, ich weiß.
Aber ich will mich nicht mit meinem Microsoft-Konto einloggen.
...wird ihr bestimmt festgestellt haben, dass das Passwort von eurem...
Ich habe mein Microsoft-Konto verknüpft.
...Gedöns aktivieren kann.
Aber zum Loggen will ich gar nicht mit meinem Microsoft-Konto verwenden.
... auch zu eurem PC-Passwort wird.
Das ist wirklich schrecklich, wenn ihr so wie ich ein 30-stelliges Passwort habt.
Weil ihr einfach auf einen Passwort-Manager setzt.
Alternativ hat man zum Glück noch die Möglichkeit...
Horror aus 30 Stellen.
Das kann ich leider nicht überprüfen, weil...
...Konto geknackt hat...
...kommt ein Update rein und ihr könnt schnell wieder mit der Arbeit anfangen.
Das ist das, was wir jetzt auf keinen Fall machen werden.
Kommt da jetzt noch irgendwas tolles an neuen Features?
Ich lost forever.
Dann wird er nicht mehr...
...Windows-Einrichtungen.
Viele davon halten, und zwar eine frische Windows-Installation.
Ihr kennt das bestimmt.
Ihr habt euch ein neues Notebook gekauft.
Und da ist schon von Haus aus viel Software drauf.
Vor allem Mac-Effie.
Das stimmt, da ist ganz viel Crap drauf.
Mac-Effie ist einfach Krebs und es ist immer auf einem PC installiert.
Und niemand weiß wieso.
Und das erste, was man machen sollte...
Ist Mac-Effie nicht im Knast?
War da nicht irgendwas letztens?
Hier ist er, John Mac-Effie.
Ist der Typ nicht im Knast?
Oder war da nicht irgendwas?
Da war doch irgendwas letztens, hab ich doch.
Ach nee, der ist nicht mehr im Knast.
Der will jetzt Präsident werden.
Ah, verstehe.
Was auch immer, der Typ geht ab.
Das Mac-Effie zu reinstallieren.
Naja, bringt alles nichts, mein System ist schon vollgemüllt.
Wer weiß was.
Und dann könnt ihr einmal frisch von neu...
Möchten Sie Windows neu installieren?
Ehrlich gesagt, nee.
...die definierte Farbe...
Oh, jetzt kommt das Killer-Feature.
Ich sehe es schon. Achtung.
Das ist eine optische Sache, aber der Funktionsumfang ist weiterhin...
Selbe.
Und unter erleichterte Bedienung kann man erstmal nicht seinen Text-Cursor komplett anpassen.
Aber wirklich anpassen, so damit du ihn nie wieder übersiehst.
Barmbrechend.
Ok, erstmal kann man natürlich die Breite weiterhin einstellen.
Aber hier oben, das übersieht man natürlich nicht.
Komplett.
Barmbrechend.
Ich hab eine Farbe, Neon-Farbe zur Auswahl.
Ich kann eine benutzerdefinierte Farbe wählen.
Zum Beispiel Orange.
Fantastik. Und dann kann ich das sogar noch ganz dick machen.
Und wenn ich jetzt das Startmenü öffne...
Eieiei.
Ich werde nie wieder den Cursor übersehen, Leute.
Ich bringe euch jetzt in die Bildschirmlupe.
Na, wer kennt nicht die Bildschirmlupe?
Oh, fuck.
Da.
Da, das ist die Bildschirmlupe.
Neuigkeit Nummer 1.
Es gibt nicht mehr die minimierte Ansicht mit der Lupe.
Kennt ihr das?
Kann es sein, dass es in Windows 10 Updates keine nennenswerten neuen Features gibt?
Oh, es geht noch weiter.
Kurz in den Einstellungen unter Personalisierung.
Farben. Die Farbe zu dunkel.
Und ihr seht...
Dark Seam.
Ironischerweise mit einem weißen Fensterrahmen.
Und der Fensterrahmen ist fast genauso groß wie die Bildschirmlupe.
Und Microsoft nicht so mit einheitlichem Design hat.
Das haben wir schon gelernt.
Das ist jetzt ja nur nichts Neues.
Das sieht immer so unfertig aus.
Das sieht alles immer so unfertig aus, was die da fabrizieren.
Ob das jetzt so sinnvoll war, sei dahingestellt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall löbelig, dass es jetzt im dunklen Design existiert.
Und es skaliert besser auf höheren Bildschirmauflösungen.
Zudem, eine Neuerung.
Die Bildschirmlupe kann jetzt vorlesen.
Inhalte.
In den Einstellungen einmal die Möglichkeit...
Oh, Microsoft Stefan.
Und die Stimme.
Was war das andere?
Microsoft Stefan und was?
Microsoft Header?
Ich gebe der Header, Alter.
Voll der Header.
Was für ein Name.
Die Stimme.
Mal gucken, wie sich Microsoft Header anhört.
Header.
Habe ich den vielleicht hier auch drauf?
Speak.
Wie lässt man sich von Windows was voll?
Narrator.
George.
Oh nee, hier.
Header. Da ist er. Header.
Ich kann Header einstellen.
Und wie kann ich mir jetzt was vorlesen lassen?
Windows-Taste und Plus.
Nee, kann ich nichts vorlesen lassen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mir was vorlesen lasse,
unter Windows, ehrlich gesagt.
Was ist das hier, Mann?
Wie?
Nein, das ist die neue Vorlesefunktion
in seinem Video.
Ich habe doch noch nicht den neuen Patch.
Was?
Wie lasse ich denn was vorlesen?
Text to Speech.
Text?
Speech.
Speech?
Ich hab doch Header.
Ah.
It's Header.
Sie haben Microsoft Header
als Standardstimme ausgewählt.
Eine Frau? Header.
You have selected Microsoft David
as the default voice.
Sie haben Microsoft Stefan
als Standardstimme ausgewählt.
Sie haben Microsoft Header
Ah, exzellent.
Microsoft Header haben wir jetzt
als Standardstimme. Die wollen die schon immer haben.
Das beste Text to Speech ist immer noch...
Korea Text to Speech
ist das beste Text to Speech.
Da kann Microsoft Header einpacken.
Die 360 Nose Scope,
den haben wir ja auch noch irgendwo, ja?
Play. Ich kann mir jetzt beispielsweise
eine Seite raussuchen. Zum Beispiel abgehakt.
So, Albert's Bananensammlung.
Ich kann jetzt...
So, das setzt man auf einen
echten Linux-Körner.
Ah ja.
Haben wir uns WSL 2 schon mal angeguckt
im Stream? Ich glaube nicht, oder?
The Preview haben wir uns glaube ich angeguckt.
Haben wir uns WSL 2 schon mal angeguckt?
Wenn nicht, müssen wir das Ganze nochmal machen,
aber wahrscheinlich
ist es
auch nur minimal besser.
Es geht nichts um eine ordentliche Linux-VM,
wenn man eine Linux braucht.
So. Das Windows Subsystem
für Linux ist nun in der Version 2
vorzufinden. Es ist realisiert
in Hyper-V. Bevor jemand fragt
Nein, ihr könnt parallel dazu nicht
Vmware nutzen.
Warum nicht?
Warum kann ich dazu nicht parallel Vmware
benutzen?
Klar geht das. Hab ich doch auch
laufen.
Ihr könnt auch weiterhin auf WSL 1
setzen.
Klar geht Vmware parallel.
Ich hatte selbst
schon WSL auf und eben bei Linux-VM
laufen. Kein Problem.
...dokumentation von Microsoft.
Die IOPen sind jetzt auch Docker ausgeführt werden.
Bevor jemand fragt,
wie nehm ich eigentliche Geld? Eine Leichtblase
hat abenteuer eine neue Stellung. Ich muss
neu klicken.
Okay, waren wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig
huge neue Features für Windows.
...
Er meint, den Vmware
Hypervisor.
...
Oh, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
So, wir gucken jetzt ein bisschen Battlefield.
Das haben wir nämlich noch nicht geguckt.
Das beste TTS ist Prime von Steamlabs.
Schau dir Battlefield Videos an.
Ja, wir gucken jetzt.
Wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Battlefield Topplays.
Die kamen nämlich letzten Sonntag oder so raus,
aber zu spät.
Da war ich schon oft mit dem Stream.
Wir wollten das letzte Woche Sonntag im Stream gucken,
aber dann gab es nicht.
Und danach habe ich mir noch ein Video gespeichert,
das wir uns angucken müssen.
Und zwar, ich habe mal wieder ein Video gefunden
von einem, der erzählt, dass Linux wunderbar zum Spielen taugt.
Da muss ich dann ein bisschen rumflamen, dass es nicht so ist.
Oder aber er stellt das Ganze realistisch dar.
Dann flame ich natürlich nicht rum.
Das Flamens wegen irgendwie rum.
Wir gucken uns das Battlefield Video an.
Und dann, für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben,
gucken wir uns nochmal mein neues Video an.
Bam!
Oh, schön.
Die hatten aber auch keinen Bock, den Heli zu bewegen,
oder, die zwei?
Was? Spank? Spank Recon?
Habe ich das richtig gehört?
Das waren die Noobs im Heli.
Das waren auch 2020 noch die Noobs, den Heli.
Und das war eine schöne TV-Messel.
So heißt das Xbox?
Nee, das ist PC.
Das ist PC in schlechter Bitrate.
Das ist aber...
Das ist aber PS4.
Boah, was geht mit dem Panzer ab?
Was zum Geier geht mit dem Panzer ab?
Oh, bäh.
Aber das war Glück.
Das war Glück.
Der war gut. Der war cool.
Und das war auch gewollt.
Das war auch gewollt.
Ich meine, sie hätte genauso gut nicht treffen können,
wenn der Heli-Mann ein bisschen anders geflogen wäre.
Aber das war gezielt prediktet,
und er wollte den treffen.
Das war nicht so ein random Schuss irgendwo in den Himmel
und hat getroffen.
Was ist denn das für eine Map?
Das ist Battlefield 4.
Ah, ist das Damm?
Die langen Dings, Damm?
Ach, das ist eine Remake.
Er weiß gar nicht, welche das ist.
Hehehe.
Dragon Valley, ja.
Ah, cool.
Das ist nice, wenn sowas klappt.
Ah, auch cool.
Was ist mit dem los?
Der ist kurz vor dem Sauerstoffmangel.
What?
Oh, das ist eine Konsolenauflösung.
Der fliegt jetzt davor, ne?
Der fliegt jetzt...
Hahaha.
Oh, das war eine nice TV-Missil.
Die haben Hacks, warum sollten die Hacks haben?
Das war wirklich...
Also, ich glaube ihm diesmal sogar,
dass das wirklich prediktet war.
Ich meine, der wusste ja, dass er ein Looping macht,
und es könnte durchaus sein, dass er es hittet.
Ich meine, es war natürlich auch Glück dabei,
bei all solchen Sachen.
Das ist langer Damm jetzt, ne?
What?
What the fuck?
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Man hat es nicht richtig gesehen,
aber da ist gerade ein Jet drüber geflogen.
Das ist nice.
Jetzt feiern sie sich ab, ey.
Moment, Leute.
Ist das Heartline?
Das sieht aus wie Heartline.
Auf der PS4.
Wahrscheinlich noch ein halb voller Surfer am Start.
360.
Los geht's.
Alter, mein Auto ist wieder weg.
Jetzt habe ich ihn anfangs nicht gesehen.
Oh, so Sachen sind immer cool.
So Sachen sind immer sehr nice.
Es ist ja immer eine Portion Glück dabei.
Klar, es gehört auch Übung dazu,
aber das ist immer nice zu sehen.
Sag mal, Chet, lebt ihr noch?
Ja, aber Glück gehabt.
Kappa, eins, zwei, drei.
Das war Glück.
Er wollte den anderen hitten.
Ich habe mal einen Pro, das muss ich mal nachmachen.
Ich habe mal einen Battlefield 3 damals,
ich nenne mal einen Pro-Chet-Pilot gesehen am Controller damals.
Also Pro, im Falle von Geld verdienen natürlich nicht,
aber einer der besten Chet-Typen,
die es damals gegeben hat auf der Konsole.
Das hat sich ungefähr so angehört mit dem Controller in der Hand,
weil du musstest ja im Battlefield 3 die Geschwindigkeit optimal halten.
Das hat sich ungefähr so angehört, wie er geflogen ist.
Das war sein Beschleunigungs-Ding vom Flugzeug.
Da wäre mir der Finger abgefallen.
Das ging 20 Minuten, das ging die komplette Runde, ging das so.
Optimalen Speed halten im Chat.
Controller-ISMA, ganz genau.
Guckt ihr lieber Corona-Chan-Infektio-ISMA an.
Da hatten wir heute ein bisschen viele Flugzeugstellklips.
Die Hexe hat letztens erzählt, er hat keinen Bock mehr auf Battlefield 4,
weil entweder nur Hacker am Start oder Server leer.
Hey Max, gibst du eigentlich auch Advice bei technischen Problemen?
Ja, aber, also erstens, ohne Gewehr, ich bin nicht dran schuld,
wenn was kaputt geht und zweitens, je nach Problem kann ich einfach nichts zu sagen.
Aber du kannst, schieß mal los.
Ja, hau rein im Chat.
Rein eliminieren, das ist nicht mehr im Trend.
Das war ja mal lange Zeit auf YouTube so angesagt,
dass man irgendwas rein eliminiert hat, das ist heute, das ist nicht mehr.
Das ist ziemlich 2014.
Oh, das war hier clean as fuck.
Richtig nice.
Geht sowas in Battlefield 5 eigentlich auch?
Kann man in Battlefield 5 aussteigen aus dem Jet,
rum durch die Luft fliegen, Panzer, Fausten dabei und wieder einsteigen?
Wenn ich laufe aus Battlefield 5 habe ich das noch nie gesehen.
Leider mich. Oh, das ist ja blöd.
Jawoll. Was, To Finish Episode?
Die Zeit ist erst zur Hälfte rum.
Da werden sie weggesprayt.
Es hat ja kaum einer Support gespielt in Battlefield 3.
Ach, das ist gar kein Rush.
Das ist schon gewonnen.
Aber richtig geiler Streak bis jetzt.
Das fand ich halt in Battlefield 3 so geil,
wenn du die Gegner erstmal in der richtigen Position hast,
kannst du so übertrieben weglatschen,
die ganzen Noobs, wie sie zurückgerannt sind.
Quasi, quasi hirnlos Richtung M-Com hier an der Stelle.
Gut, es ist jetzt kein M-Com da.
Das war in Battlefield 3 mal unerreicht in dieser Noob-Bash-Potenzial.
Ich werde so übelst weggesprayt.
Das ist mal ein richtig geiler Streak.
Das ist auch nice einzurichten.
Vor allem wegen der Suppression treffen sie alle wieder nichts.
Und dann sind wir noch nicht fertig.
Das riecht ein richtig cooler Streak bis jetzt.
Es gab im Chat eine Frage.
Und zwar schreibt er, habe gestern eine neue Version von Q-Bit-Torrent installiert.
Ich habe aber scheinbar einen Bug bei der neuen Version
und ich wollte wieder downgraden.
Leider buggen jetzt aber auch die Installer rum.
Immer wenn ich die Exe der Anwendung anklicke, startet diese nicht.
Dafür friert das Windows-Explorer-Fenster ein.
Boah, kein Schimmer.
Das ist Windows gedönst.
Ich will gucken, dass ich das Ding komplett so clean wie möglich
wieder deinstalliert kriege
und mir von einer möglichst offiziellen Quelle
die alte Version nochmal besorge.
Leider hat ja Windows bis heute keinen Paketmanager,
mit dem man sowas machen kann.
Dann wäre das total easy.
Aber Microsoft hat sich gedacht,
braucht man nicht, ist überflüssig.
Gibt es noch volle Server?
Ja, aber nicht viele.
So zwei, drei.
Half-Life schon mit Brille gekauft?
Nee, ich will mir auch keine VR-Brille kaufen.
Das habe ich mir überlegt, weil ich würde das eine Game
mit VR-Brille spielen und sonst nichts.
Das wäre komplett rausgeschmitztes Geld.
Kommt eigentlich ein Video zu den neuen Konsolen, also der Hardware?
Nee, ich gehe gar nicht zurück zur Konsole.
Das rantiert nicht.
Weiß nicht, ob ich ein neues Video machen soll
zum Thema Konsolen, weil
das ist ein Thema, das wurde schon ziemlich breit getreten
und man muss auch mal ehrlich sagen, so viel gibt es nicht zu sagen.
Die Dinger sind sehr ähnlich,
auch wenn rein von den Zahlen her
Grafikkarte und CPU-mäßig die Xbox die Nase vorn hat,
IO-Storage-mäßig die PS4 ein bisschen die Nase vorn hat,
aber unterm Strich ändert sich da,
es ist kaum ein Unterschied von der Hardware.
Kein großer zumindest.
Denke 8-Kerner werden dann auch auf dem PC mindestens anfordert?
Glaube ich nicht.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass es gehörig dazu beitragen wird,
dass die Spiele noch mehr Kerne gut verdauen.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es eine SSD mindestens an Forderung geben wird.
Ich habe eh so meine Zweifel, inwieweit dieser Ultra-SSD-Speed
nur Marketing ist oder wirklich das großartige was bringt.
Dafür bin ich zu wenig Spiele-Programmierer,
um das gut einschätzen zu können.
Wann ist der perfekte Zeitpunkt, einen PC zusammenzubauen?
Immer dann, wenn der aktuelle einem zu langsam ist.
Großartig zu warten lohnt sich meistens nicht.
Es gibt ab und zu mal Ausnahmen,
also wenn ich weiß, dass nächste Woche irgendwas ist,
was dazu führen könnte, dass die Hardware massiv billiger wird,
dann schon, aber in der Regel lohnt es sich nicht großartig zu warten.
Was hältst du von Apache Mesos?
Muss ich ehrlich sagen, habe ich schon nichts mitgemacht.
Also bis jetzt noch nicht.
Das ist ja quasi die Open Source Apache Kubernetes-Geschichte.
Da habe ich noch nichts mitgemacht.
Das war's für heute.
Was ist das für eine Waffe? Ist das eine ACR?
Eigentlich steht das sogar da, ACE 23.
Oh, das war, das war Payne's Champ, Witze.
Massive Payne.
Da steht einfach ein Klo rum.
Da steht einfach random ein Klo.
Boah, das ist aber auch ein, also es ist auch ein ultra heftiger Streak hier.
Also ich werde es jetzt so machen, falls ihr euch fragt, was mit dem Battlefield Top Plays ist.
Ich habe ja hier im Stream gesagt, wir wollen Battlefield, Battlefield Top Plays machen.
Die kommen am Wochenende. Ich habe jetzt ja gerade ein Video aufgenommen gestern.
Vorgestern, gestern hochgeladen.
Ich mache wahrscheinlich morgen eins, wo ich mich nochmal über die ganze Homeoffice-Geschichte und Leute, die sie hier gebacken kriegen, auslassen muss.
Und am Samstag oder Sonntag kommt das Battlefield-Video.
Ja, die G18 ist eh geil.
Die G18 klatscht rein.
Man kann, man kann ohne Probleme 200 FPS haben im Battlefield 4.
Er wird ja auch nicht, das ist jetzt Epilepsie-Warnung-Bild hier.
Das hatte man damals schon, wenn man die Qualität nicht ganz auf Max gestellt hat.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass Battlefield ein Spiel ist, was richtig von vielen FPS profitiert.
Das fühlt sich einfach, ein Battlefield fühlt sich mit 200 FPS einfach doppelt so gut an wie mit 60.
Der eine ist bis heute eines meiner Lieblingsmaps.
Wobei ich ja sagen muss, meine Lieblingsrushmap im Battlefield 3 ist immer noch Terran Highway.
Komplett underrated Map, erwähnt niemand, wenn es um Top-Maps geht.
Aber ich finde Terran Highway ist eine richtig gute Rushmap von der Abwechslung her.
Du hast die Panzer-Base-Action am Anfang, dann geht es runter die Straße ein bisschen in die Häuserkampfzone rein und dann den Highway hoch an die Endbasis.
Terran Highway habe ich immer extrem gerne gespielt.
Natürlich so die Klassiker hier, Basar, Demavent Peak und so sind auch geil.
Aber ich muss sagen, Terran Highway ist persönlich meine Lieblingsrushmap aus Battlefield 3 wohlgemerkt.
Meine Lieblingsrushmap insgesamt würde ich sagen, das ist so ein bisschen schwierig.
Also Port Valdas ist auf jeden Fall weit vorne, wobei Port Valdas ein bisschen ekelige Choke Points hatte.
Die ganzen Bad Company 2 Maps und teilweise auch die Bad Company 1 Maps sind extrem geile Rushmaps.
Aus Battlefield 3 würde ich aber sagen, Terran Highway und natürlich auch Basar und Demavent Peak und Sand Crossing.
Battlefield 3 hatte schon auch sehr viele geile Rushmaps.
Wobei ich ja sagen muss, dass gerade Firestorm und Caspian Border überhaupt nicht mein Fall waren.
Da waren total viele geile drauf, war ja halt Panzer-Action und Flugzeug-Action, aber ich war halt kein Flugzeugmann in Battlefield 3.
Deswegen fand ich Caspian Border und Firestorm gar nicht so toll.
Ja, Roffel 143. Ich sage ja, das werden für einige nicht verstehen, aber es hat jeder so seinen Geschmack und meins war es in Battlefield 3 nicht.
Oh Gott, jetzt wird Spawn gecampt. Spawn-Camp geht los, Leute.
Spawn-Camp ist raus.
Wie oft man hier die Gegner im Spawn hatte, ne?
Wie oft man hier die Gegner im Spawn hatte. Die Spawn-Punkte in Battlefield 3 waren wirklich auch nicht alle geil.
Also das ist schon, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Top-Play ist. Also jetzt, der erste Teil war schon nice.
Aber das hier, ich meine, da habe ich auch teilweise 5 Minuten am Stück einfach nur an der Ecke gelegen und alles weggeschnetzelt.
Und dann lagen, genau wie hier, lagen so viele Gegner, die noch auf Respawn-Timer gewartet haben, dass du gar nicht wusstest, ist es jetzt ein Gegner oder ist es noch eine Leiche, die in Respawn ist.
Dann auch noch meine Lieblingswaffe aus Battlefield 3.
Was ist, was ist das für eine Waffe?
Die habe ich glaube ich nicht einmal ausgerüstet, die Waffe. Schneiber. Nicht einmal ausgerüstet.
Boah, aber cool hier, da macht die ganz schön platt.
Cooler Clip ist es auf jeden Fall.
Was zur Hoffnung hast du für Bad Company 3? Ne, die größte Hoffnung, die ich für Bad Company 3 habe, ist, dass es erstmal rauskommt.
Weil angeblich ist es ja gar nicht mehr in Entwicklung. Aber wie gesagt, Gerüchte über Gerüchte, da kann man ja nichts drauf geben.
Aber es wurde ja weder offiziell bestätigt, noch irgendwas dazu gesagt. Also man kann eigentlich nur hoffen, dass es überhaupt mal irgendwann rankommt.
Boah, wie? Bad Company 3, wenn das nicht... Ich glaube es erst, wenn ich es sehe, Bad Company 3.
Ne, dieses Jahr kommt kein neues Battlefield. Ein neues Battlefield kommt wahrscheinlich nächstes Jahr.
Und dann mal gucken. Und dann müssen sie langsam aber sicher, na wobei, ne, müssen sie nicht, weil Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 haben sich ja sogar ganz gut verkauft.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre das jetzt der totale Rheinfall gewesen. Ist es ja gar nicht mal. Die müssen eigentlich gar nichts, was ich sag, machen.
Leider.
And the second clip he sent in is on Flood Zone with the AEK. A bit of a different clip this one. It's more of a PTFO clip, as he looks to get onto the objectives on Rush.
Very rare that I get sent in a Flood Zone Rush clip, but a really awesome one. So enjoy this slightly rare and unique clip that you won't often see on Battlefield 4.
What? Und wo? Hat er gerade eine Granate bei sich von Fuß geschmissen? Nee, das war ein Med-Pak. Med-Pak, ne?
Das Aim war aber ziemlich on point die letzten paar Gegner.
Da kannst du nichts sagen.
Oh, noch die Legehennen gemacht. So gehört sich das.
Eine richtig nice Legehennen. Die Gegner! Die Gegner! Please!
Gegner! Es schmerzt!
Wenn das Absicht war, dass er sich einen Schuss übrig gelassen hat bei der AEK zum schneller Nachladen, dann war das der massivste Big Brainplay, den ich heute gesehen habe.
Er spielt bestimmt gerade aus der Quarantäne. Alle Zeit.
Zack! In your face!
Ich wusste nicht mal, dass die Waffe überhaupt so heißt. Die Gegner! Please! Gegner! Ihr macht mich fertig! Was ist mit euch los?
Die Gegner sind wieder so hohl. Also es ist nicht, dass er schlecht spielen könnte oder so. Ich meine, die Snipes sind übel nice und auch immer direkt draufgekommen. Aber die Gegner!
Also so gut er spielt, so gut müssen die Gegner auch mitspielen, dass das funktioniert.
Die Shotgun-Spielswörter werden gleich geflamet nach der ersten Runde.
Na ja, die ist aber auch nicht so 100% zuverlässig.
Haha, der hat sich das auch nicht so gedacht. Das ist das, warum ich nie gerne Shotgun gespielt habe in Battlefield, weil die Dinger so zu 90% One-Hitten und ab und zu rechnest du nicht, damit uns überlebt einer.
ZaitoTV, schick her! Aber nur wenn es gut ist!
Die checken wieder nichts!
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass es da so viele Noobs noch gibt in dem Spiel. Ich meine, die hatten jetzt wie lange? 7 Jahre Zeit oder so? Nee, nicht ganz. 6 Jahre Zeit? Nicht mehr Noobs zu sein?
Da kriegst du ein A-Amm von den Gegnern, ja.
Haha, was für eine Range! Habt ihr das gesehen? Was für eine Range am Ende mit der Shotgun!
Da machen ja manche Sniper schon kein One-Hit mehr auf die Entfernung, wo der gerade mit der Shotgun One-Hitted hat.
Ein Nices Video wieder.
Aber nicht schlägt enemyac130 im Buff. Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Haha, das ist immer noch der beste Ansager.
Das brauchen wir eigentlich fast im Meme-Born schon, oder? Was sagt ihr dazu, Leute?
Auf jeden Fall.
Gut, mach ich rein.
Tango Sucker, genau.
Tango Sucker. Was? Oh, das ist mein Video.
Ich krieg mein eigenes Video hervor.
Jetzt will er uns hier... Ach ja, immer Frage an euch. Wollen wir jetzt eigentlich noch zusammen mein letztes Video angucken oder nicht?
Dein Pfaffkott. Schwer zu sagen. Ich würde sagen Black Ops 1.
Black Ops 1 hatte, finde ich, das beste Gesamtpaket.
MW2 war auch cool, wobei ich sagen muss, aus heutiger Sicht, der MW2-Multiplayer war der Anfang vom Ende im Endeffekt.
Was schnell sterben und random Tode und so angeht. Da fand ich Black Ops 1 schon deutlich besser.
MW2 hatte aber auf jeden Fall coole Sachen. Ich weiß noch, wie nice die Spec Ops-Missionen mit dem Friseur zusammen waren.
Diese Co-Op Spec Ops-Missionen. Die haben ultra Bock gemacht.
Einmal nur Co-Op mit jemand zusammen.
Mein Lieblings-Battlefield.
Das ist schwer zu sagen. Für sich genommen sind Bad Company 1, 2, Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 nice Games.
Ich würde sagen Battlefield 3.
Wobei Bad Company 1 und vor allem Bad Company 2 auch extrem geil waren.
Ich würde das sogar eher rein von dem, wie viel Zeit ich reingesteckt habe und wie viel ich gespielt habe und auch was ich alles gemacht habe.
Dann doch Battlefield 3.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal.
Guck mal, ich kriege sogar Highlight, weil Corona im Titel vorkommt.
Weil Corona im Titel vorkommt, kriege ich sogar angezeigt unter mein Video.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max und ich muss sagen, ich mag...
Viel zu leise. Max, du bist viel zu leise. Warum bist du so leise? Was soll das?
Max, du bist immer noch so leise.
Wir gucken jetzt nochmal mein eigenes Video.
Für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max und ich muss sagen, ich mag Corona.
Da fühle ich mich echt so ganz... Jetzt Lautstärke ist okay, oder?
Ja, es haben viele geschrieben, das wirkt für sie wie ein Comedyprogramm, das war überhaupt nicht so gedacht.
Ich habe mir nur ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben.
Vorher, was ich sagen will.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max und ich muss sagen, ich mag Corona.
Da fühle ich mich echt so ganz wie daheim. Wunderbar.
Aktuell muss ich Deutschland mit einem Thema beschäftigen, was ganz viele Leute zu schaffen macht, nämlich sozialer Distanz.
Das ist eine Wortkreation, von der ich gar nicht wusste, dass die überhaupt existiert bis vor ein paar Tagen.
Mittlerweile ist das ja in aller Munde soziale Distanz, Kontaktverbot, Kontaktsperre und damit haben richtig viele Leute ganz, ganz schwierig.
Also für die ist das ganz schwer und haben ganz viele Probleme.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich ein Thema, mit dem wir als Gamer und echte Hacker-Mans natürlich bestens vertraut sind.
Auch ganz ohne Corona.
Aber für die normalen Casuals und Leute ist das echt ein Problem.
Die wissen nicht, was sie machen sollen.
So ohne andere Menschen und teilweise auch mit weniger Sonnenlicht und solchen Sachen.
Bei mir war es umgedreht. Ich habe mich die letzten Jahre eher gefragt,
Scheiße, was mache ich denn mit anderen Menschen zusammen?
Bei mir liegt es einfach daran, ich mag andere Menschen nicht.
Natürlich meine YouTube-Subs und Twitch-Subs selbstverständlich ausgenommen, weil Schleim, Schleim und so.
Da können wir eigentlich ja nur drüber lachen.
Das ist für mich so wunderbar. Jetzt geht es mal...
Nein, das ist nicht live. Das ist mein letztes Video. Ich verstehe, dass es ein wenig verwirrend ist.
Wie findest du eigentlich deine G513? Ich habe keine G513, ich habe eine G403.
So wie es mir geht. Nur gezwungenermaßen.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema andere Menschen sind.
Vor ein paar Tagen, als die ganze Corona-Geschichte schon in vollem Gange war
und auch schon offizielle Meldungen raus waren, die Leute sollen ein bisschen Abstand halten,
nicht so viele Leute, nicht so viele Gruppen, also nicht so viele Leute auf engem Raum in Gruppen zusammen.
Bin ich ja mein lang gelaufen zum Rewe.
Bei uns beim Rewe ist ja einkaufen gehen, ist ja mittlerweile auch schon abenteuerlich geworden, das Ganze.
Deswegen, ich mache es wie bisher, ich bestelle das meist aus dem Internet.
Das ist ja auch was, was für viele absoluten...
Den habe ich auch schön zusammenge... Ich wollte gerade sagen gefotoshopt, aber es ist nicht wirklich gefotoshopt.
Den habe ich doch schön zusammengebaut, den Boomer und den Apple CRT-Monitor, oder?
Twitch-React auf eigenes Video, huge sixhead.
Neuland mittlerweile ist, wie man kann im Internet bestellen.
Was, man kann sogar Klopapier im Internet bestellen.
Oh, das hätte ich jetzt aber nicht gedacht.
Es ist unglaublich, wie überrascht manche Leute über solche Sachen sind, dass das tatsächlich möglich ist.
Zumindest, ich bin am mein lang gelaufen zum Rewe,
erstmal an der Kneipe vorbeigelaufen, sitzen da Leute drin, keine Ahnung, 5, 6, 7, 8 Leute, 20 cm Abstand, besaufen sich.
Ja, das ist vielleicht keine allzu gute Idee.
Danach kamen wir in Familienausflug entgegen mit drei Pärchen...
Oh, viel zu laut, viel zu laut eigentlich, das Sound, den ich reingespuckt und brei gemacht habe.
Fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Aber...
Kinder waren Kinder, bestimmt auch 15 Leute oder so.
Ja, hat keinen was gejuckt.
Danach, am Main, auf einer Decke, an die 20 Leute, auf einer riesen Decke, Picknick gemacht, so richtig YOLO, juckt uns alles nicht.
Das habe ich ja sogar noch auf Twitter geschrieben, die Leute, die ich beim Picknick erwischt habe.
Am Main.
Also, was man daran wieder sieht, ist, wenn man sich darauf verlassen muss, auf andere Leute, dann ist man komplett verlassen.
In Italien kriegen sie es jetzt ja mittlerweile auch halbwegs hin.
Da sitzen sie auf dem Balkon und singen zusammen.
Bei uns juckt das noch nicht so viele Leute.
Am besten gehen die danach noch abends zur Oma essen und wundern sich hoch, warum hustet die Oma auf einmal?
Ja, woran könnte das nur liegen?
Gut, das dauert ja meistens ein bisschen länger.
Aber das ist den Leuten dann wahrscheinlich vollkommen unerklärlich, wie von uns, ja von uns können die das ja gar nicht haben.
Da rad ich echt drauf.
Wobei, mittlerweile singen wir ja auch.
Das ging vor ein paar Tagen ja über die ganzen Social Networks.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Auf Twitter oder an die Freude, Hashtag.
Das war so schrecklich teilweise die Leute.
Da haben welche gesungen, haben Trompete gespielt und Geige gespielt.
Das war so unglaublich schäpp alles.
Spielst du gerade deinen YouTube wieder?
Ja, ich spiele gerade meinen YouTube wieder.
Das haben doch nicht alle gesehen.
Dass wir jetzt auch ohne an die Freude gesungen haben.
Leute haben am Fenster teilweise sehr schäpp ohne an die Freude gesungen.
Ob sich da Schiller und Beethoven so gedacht haben, weiß ich nicht.
Was mich ja persönlich gewundert hat, ist, dass wir ohne an die Freude gesungen haben und nicht Helene Fischer atemlos oder sowas.
Damit hätte ich ehrlich gesagt...
Ich muss sagen, das war ein guter Witz.
...rechnet. Zumal das auch ganz gut zum Thema Lungenentzündung passt.
Sowohl vom Texte als auch vor allem von der Musik her.
Es gab auf Twitter zig Videos, wo die Leute zusammen am Fenster gestanden haben und zusammen Musik gemacht haben.
Fenster ist ja ein gutes Thema, weil am Anfang bei dieser ganzen Corona-Geschichte ging das Gerücht um, Bill Gates ist dran schuld.
Bill Gates hätte da schon irgendwie ein Mittel dagegen und will das jetzt verprügeln.
Green Zero zeige ich dir gleich.
Was auch immer man sich da wieder zusammenfantasiert hat.
Zum Thema Verschwörungstheorien komme ich gleich noch.
Das Video hat etwas von Stand-Up-Komitee.
Ja, viele haben geschrieben, dabei war das überhaupt nicht so geplant.
Ich habe mir halt im Vorfeld was aufgeschrieben dazu.
Tolle neue Entwicklung.
Aber wo ich mir dann so gedacht habe, Bill Gates, wie kommt ihr auf Bill Gates?
Ausgerechnet Bill Gates.
Und habe ich mal auf YouTube geguckt.
Ich verstehe nicht.
Bill Gates hat tatsächlich vor...
Das, ey, da muss ich jetzt mal...
Das war ja wirklich...
Verschwörungsmäßig Bill Gates ist dran schuld.
Wie kommt man echt ausgerechnet auf Bill Gates?
Das ist einer der Milliardäre, die ausgesprochen viel für die Allgemeinheit machen.
Dass ausgerechnet Bill Gates daran schuld ist, weiß ich keine...
Das ist hart Illuminati.
Ich glaube, vier oder fünf Jahre mal einen Talk gehalten auf irgendeiner Konferenz.
Zum Thema Epidemien und Viren und sowas.
Und außerdem mal Windows 95.
Dieses Jahr 25-jähriges Jubiläum.
Also wenn das nicht genug Beweis dafür ist, dass Bill Gates...
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen uns Windows 95 installieren, oder?
Wann ist das? Im April oder so?
Die ganze Sache schuld ist, da weiß ich auch nicht.
Langsam ergibt alles Sinn, Leute.
Ja, was gibt es denn sonst noch so Schönes?
Genau, also auf Twitter werden wieder Gehirnzellen verbrannt.
Und zwar kennt ihr schon die Corona-Challenge.
Also ihr müsst jetzt nicht nachgucken.
Lasst es lieber bleiben, ich erzähle euch, was die Corona-Challenge ist.
Und zwar gibt es ein paar Leute, die finden sich wahnsinnig geil,
wenn sie öffentlich Türklinken ablecken oder Rolltreppen oder Klodeckel ablecken.
Alter.
So bescheuert muss der erstmal sein.
Das klingt jetzt so, als hätte ich mir das ausgedacht, aber das ist wirklich so.
Das läuft unter dem Hashtag Corona-Challenge.
Die einzige Hoffnung, die es aus meiner Sicht für diese Leute noch gibt, ist,
dass die sich wirklich Corona holen und dass vielleicht die Chance besteht,
dass sich Coronaviren irgendwie insgeheim noch in Gehirnzellen umwandeln können.
Ansonsten sehe ich schwarz.
Ansonsten kommen die Leute wohl nie wieder auf den grünen Zweig,
wenn so was Bescheuer das macht.
Wisst ihr, worüber ich auch...
Lachen über eigene Gags ist tatsächlich fast schon Payne's Jam.
Wirklich ziemlich lachen musste.
Wo ich mir echt drüber kaputt gelacht habe,
und zwar bei der Meldung, dass die Schulen versuchen, Online-Unterricht zu machen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, was?
In Deutschland? Mit welcher Infrastruktur, mit welchem Internet, mit welchem Personal, mit was?
Da wäre es ja sinnvoller, hätten die einfach nur einen Overhead-Projektor mit 70 Millionen Watt
und würden das irgendwie an den Himmel werfen, so Batman-Style.
Das würde besser funktionieren, als wenn unsere Schulen versuchen würden, Online-Unterricht zu machen.
Den Gag habe ich ein bisschen geklaut, bei der einen Rositas-Verarsche.
Weiß ich gar nicht, wie die das Ganze hinbekommen sollen.
Naja, die Welt ist aktuell schon ein bisschen am Durchdrehen.
Zum Beispiel hat unsere Bundeskanzlerin öffentlich von Skypen gesprochen im Fernsehen, in 2020.
Also wir haben nicht 2015, 2014, sondern so 2020.
Also eine Software, die seit fünf Jahren schon echt keinen Menschen mehr interessiert.
Aber ich muss hier zur Gute halten, Discorden hört sich auch echt doof an, oder?
Schulen machen jetzt übrigens WhatsApp-Gruppen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es das Einzige ist, was die Boomer-Lehrer bedienen können.
Und WhatsApp kann halt jeder irgendwie bedienen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe es nicht irgendwelche Alternativen dazu.
Und an mir geht das Ganze natürlich auch nicht spurlos vorbei.
Ich meine, ich habe mir 96 Rollen Klopapier bestellt online.
Und ihr wisst, das stimmt.
Und ich wurde auf Twitter, waren sie schon am Starten, haben gesagt,
Max, das wäre extrem unmoralisch.
Und jetzt haben sie auf YouTube auch angefangen, wie unmoralisch das wäre,
dass ich mir 96 Rollen Klopapier bestellt habe.
Ich habe mir da einfach nur dazu gedacht.
Was juckt es mich? Dafür kann ich mir den Arsch abwischen, ey. Und die anderen nicht.
Obwohl ich ein Klo habe mit eingebauter Dusche und eigentlich so gut wie kein Klopapier mehr brauche.
Ich habe eine Atemschutzmaske daheim.
Und eigentlich habe ich mir die aber nicht für Corona gekauft, ne.
Die habe ich mir schon vor einer Weile und zwar für Heimwerkerzwecke gekauft,
wenn man mal Sachen mit Schimmel und solche Sachen wegmachen muss.
Aber es ist praktisch, dass man jetzt sowas hat.
Also es passt wirklich, hat das richtig gut zusammengepasst, dass ich mir sowas gekauft habe.
Und ja, bevor mir jetzt wieder die ersten Leute erzählen wollen,
Max, das hilft nicht gegen Viren. Doch, diese Maske hilft gegen Viren.
Glaubt es mir und wenn ihr es mir nicht glaubt, geht es auf ein zukünftiges Bild von meiner Atemschutzmaske.
Ich zeige euch die Maske gleich.
Das ist nicht so eine popelige kleine Minipapiermaske, das ist eine richtige.
Das kann man wegen Maske nennen, was ich da am Start habe.
Ja, vor zwei Wochen hat uns übrigens Twitter noch erzählt,
dass Corona natürlich nur alte, reiche Männer betrifft.
Also schon mal niemand von uns.
Ernsthaft, ne? Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Da haben sie sich auf Twitter aufgegeilt, weil irgendjemand erzählt hat,
weil auf irgendeinem Live-Auftritt eine Band gesagt hat,
Corona trifft nur alte, weiche, weiße oder alte, reiche.
Man hat sich so ganz verstanden, Männer.
Oh, und da haben sie sich aufgeregt, so nach dem Motto hier.
Das wäre ja schon so unfassbar, was hier erzählt wird und so.
Und dann kamen die anderen so nach dem Motto, ja wieso ist doch so?
Da hab ich mir gedacht, Alter, ich muss Twitter manchmal,
ich muss es früher schließen, bevor ich anfange, mir den Kram durchzulegen.
Durchzulesen.
Also es gab wirklich welche, die darauf bestanden haben, das wäre so.
Ja, weil wir da auch so große Unterschied machen.
Zumindest ist der Aluhut allgemein auch nicht weit.
Denn, falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet, wie das Ganze in Wirklichkeit zusammensteht,
aktuelle Verschwörungstheorien erklären uns das Ganze nämlich.
Falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet, und zwar in Wuhan, in China,
oder in China, wie manche Leute das sagen.
Ich sage lieber China.
China oder China?
Oder wie man es in Hessen so sagt, China.
Also der 5G-Ausbau in Wuhan, in China, ist ziemlich gut.
Das ist natürlich ein Zustand, der aus deutscher Sicht quasi unmöglich ist.
Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Wie kann ein 5G-Ausbau funktionieren, das geht nicht.
Das heißt, da kann es schon mal nicht mit rechten Dingen zugehen, offensichtlicherweise.
Und deswegen muss man...
Oder China. China ergeht natürlich auch.
Wenn wir jetzt auch mal der Wahrheit ins Gesicht blicken,
nämlich, dass Corona in Wirklichkeit ein 5G-Gedanken-Virus ist.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Es gibt wirklich aktuelle Verschwörungstheorien dazu,
die uns das Ganze zu erzählen wollen.
Werden zum Beispiel in Zügen Flyer ausgelegt, 5G-Corona-Gedanken-Virus.
Weil 5G-Ausbau in Wuhan ist ja auch ziemlich weit vorne.
Schon bestechende Logik, muss ich sagen.
Nachdem Angela Merkel, also unsere Bundeskanzlerin jetzt ja auch,
selbst in Quarantäne ist seit, glaube ich, zwei Tagen oder so,
macht sie sich vielleicht mal ein bisschen Gedanken über das Internet in Deutschland.
Ich stelle mir das gerade so vor.
Die sitzt daheim im Homeoffice, will gerade Putin anrufen über Skype.
Und dann muss sie erstmal zur Fritzbox und die Fritzbox neu starten.
Das kann ich mir so gut vorstellen.
Das kann ich mir so gut vorstellen, hier einfach bei uns im Internet auszubauen.
Bis die Merkel ihren Router neu gestartet hat,
haben die Chinesen in der Zwischenzeit schon zwei komplett neue Internetknotenpunkte
aus der Erde gebuddelt mit 20 Millionen Bagger.
In der Zeit ist die Fritzbox noch nie mal gebootet, bis was hinhaut.
Die Chinesen haben sich mit dem Bagger bis zum Erdmettelpunkt durchgebuddelt,
bis die Fritzbox von der neu gestartet ist.
Das geht Highspeed bei denen.
... den Vodafone-Support anschreiben.
Ja, Frau Merkel, schicken Sie uns bitte Ihre Kundennummer.
Oh, Ihr WLAN funktioniert nicht, das liegt bestimmt am WLAN.
Ja, wie gesagt, Vodafone, Unity Media.
Ich hatte in letzter Zeit schon wieder sehr viel Spaß mit dem Verein.
Tja, was gibt es sonst noch so zu sagen?
Manche haben ja die Hoffnung, dass das Ganze gut für die Umwelt ist.
Und aktuell, wenn man sich Satellitenbilder anguckt und so Luftverschmutzungswerte,
ist das aktuell auch ziemlich gut.
Also die Umweltverschmutzung bzw. die Luftverschmutzung ist deutlich zurückgegangen.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch klar.
Was sagt ihr eigentlich zu meinem Atemschutzmasken-Keks?
Huge Photoshop-Skills, oder?
Läuft ja auch gerade nichts mehr.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass das von langer Dauer sein wird.
Ich glaube, das wird das komplette Gegenteil werden,
wenn die Leute, wenn die ganze Corona-Geschichte erstmal durch ist.
11 von 10.
Dann werden die Leute erstmal alles nachholen,
was sie jetzt die letzten Monate nicht machen konnten und richtig abgehen.
Und manche Leute haben vielleicht jetzt auch festgestellt, oh Mist, so wie das jetzt ist.
Wenn wir umweltbewusst leben, dann ist das ja vielleicht immer so.
Oh nee, das wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall.
Nee, nee, das geht nicht. Lieber in your face weiter geht's.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass Corona irgendwelche Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt haben wird.
Ich meine, wo kämen wir denn dahin?
Wenn Corona vorbei ist und alle Leute wieder im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes durchatmen können,
wo kämen wir denn dahin, wenn das überall auf der Welt auch so sein könnte?
Also da muss schon wieder ein bisschen ordentlich Umwelt- und Luftverschmutzung hochgefahren werden,
wenn Corona durch ist.
Da kannst du Gift drauf nehmen, dass wenn die Sache vorbei ist, ist wie als wäre nichts gewesen.
Mich würde alles andere sehr wundern.
Aber eine Sache frage ich mich echt.
Jetzt ernsthaft mal, frage ich mich wirklich.
Letztens kam im Radio so ein Spot, so Hessen bedankt sich bei Krankenpflegerinnen,
Krankenpfleger, Arzthelferinnen und Krankenhauspersonal.
Und es ist eine schöne Geste, wenn sich Hessen bei denen bedankt.
Aber ich denke mir so...
Fuck Leute, ich habe mich versprochen im Video.
Ich habe nicht gesagt Krankenpfleger und Krankenpflegerinnen.
Ich hoffe, das sehen nicht die falschen Leute.
Kritisch.
Anzeige ist raus, ja.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wenn man doch aktuell so wieviel 750 Milliarden oder sonst was aus dem Ärmel schütteln kann
für die Wirtschaft, bäm, ist da.
Warum kann man nicht den Leuten, die da gerade an vorderster Front stehen,
mal ein bisschen was von der ganzen Sache zukommen lassen?
Sei es mal so, keine Ahnung, 50% Gefahrenzulage oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich meine, es ist ja gut, dass viele Leute das aus Überzeugung machen
und das machen auch, weil sie anderen Menschen helfen wollen.
Aber ein bisschen Kohle können die dafür doch auch bekommen.
Warum gibt man denen nicht mal ein bisschen was ab?
Das fände ich schön, ja.
Und bei der Gelegenheit könnte man gleich noch ein paar deutsche
oder meinetwegen auch internationale Influencer von YouTube auch in Quarantäne schicken.
Dann wäre man zumindest von manchen Leuten verschont.
Na gut.
Ja, so viel zum Thema Corona von mir.
Eine gute Sache am Schluss, wo ich jetzt mal loswerden,
das Ganze finde ich wirklich ernsthaft.
Ich finde, man sieht...
Da hat sich einer in den Kommentaren darüber beschwert,
was ich jetzt gleich sage, dass das Millionen Menschen das Leben kosten wird.
Ich weiß nicht, wie er den Zusammenhang herstellt, aber guckt dran.
Gut, dass es vollkommen egal ist, was wir so machen.
Oder es ist gut, dass das jeder Einzelne mal sieht.
Es kommt den Leuten teilweise so unglaublich wichtig vor, was sie machen.
Und was man daran sieht, ist halt, die Welt dreht sich weiter.
Egal für wie wichtig man sich hält, die Welt dreht sich weiter.
Und auch eine Sache, wo ich denke, dass das die ganze Corona-Geschichte
einen großen Einfluss darauf haben könnte, ist,
dass vielleicht sich das Thema Homeoffice bei ein bisschen mehr Unternehmen durchsetzt.
Aber ich glaube, eine wichtige Erkenntnis für viele Leute dürfte echt sein,
dass man eben einsieht, hey, egal wie wichtig ich denke, dass ich bin
und wie viel Sachen drum herum passieren, die Welt dreht sich weiter.
Mit mir oder ohne mich.
Es ist vollkommen egal.
Hör mal, Herr Steiner, Schluss.
Ja, also ich glaube, dass das wirklich ein großer Vorteil von dieser ganzen Geschichte ist,
weil viele Leute nehmen das, was sie machen, viel zu wichtig.
Die denken, es geht ohne sie überhaupt nichts.
Oder wenn sie was nicht machen würden, dann wäre das, dann ist das der Weltuntergang.
Und was man gerade bei dieser Corona-Geschichte sieht,
es ist nicht der Weltuntergang.
Es macht ehrlich gesagt, interessiert sich die Welt absolut gar nicht dafür,
was ein einzelner Typ macht oder nicht macht.
Bei Milliarden von Leuten sieht es schon wieder anders aus.
Also es kam die Frage, wie ich meine G513-Tastatur finde.
Finde ich gut.
Besser als die doppelt so teure von Corsair.
Dann hatten wir noch die Frage, ob ich mal meine Atemschutzmaske zeigen kann.
Ja, kann ich machen.
Das zeige ich.
Und zwar meine Atemschutzmaske ist hier.
Da ist er doch.
Da ist er.
So wie gesagt, es ist halt eine richtig echte.
Also sowas, was man wirklich Maske nennen kann.
So komplett zu.
Und die Filter sind auch gegen Viren geeignet.
Habe ich mir eigentlich gekauft für mein Metro-Cosplay.
Aber jetzt kann ich es ja auch für Corona verwenden.
Sogar mit Filter, ja klar.
Das wäre ziemlich blöd, oder?
Wobei mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn irgendwelche Leute mit dieser Maske rumlaufen würden.
Und hätten nichts angeschlossen.
Und laufen einfach so rum.
Was gibt es eigentlich?
Ich muss gerade mal was wohnen.
Corona-Resitas.
Was gibt es da eigentlich so?
Resita Hamsterkäufe und Corona.
Corona Klopapier.
Wie lange halten die Filter?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Komm, wir gucken uns doch mal eine Resitas Verarsche an.
Oder eine Resita Untertitelgeschichte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die gut ist.
Das ist einfach die erste, die ich genommen habe.
Resitas mit der Schule und digital war gut.
Okay, jetzt happening.
Naja, gut. Naja, gut.
Naja, unwichtig ist Klopapier nicht. Weiß gar nicht, warum sie sich alle so extrem darüber lustig machen.
Stellt euch mal vor, du hast keinen richtigen Vorrat Klopapier und du kriegst wirklich Corona.
Und bist drei bis vier Wochen daheim. Du musst trotz Corona scheißen und du kannst nicht einkaufen.
Also ein bisschen Klopapier Vorrat ist nicht verkehrt.
Okay, da vorher war echt ganz lustig.
Okay, das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Okay, das war wirklich nicht schlecht.
Bambino, Bono, Twitchbleiben, Dankeschön.
Residus prepares himself vor Corona Virus.
Moment, die machen sich alle über Klopapier lustig.
What the fuck. Die machen sich alle über Klopapier lustig.
Moment, wir müssen mal filtern, upload diesen Monat.
Warum nutzt du eigentlich Chromium? Hat keinen tieferen Grund mehr aktuell.
Ich hab mal ursprünglich Chromium verwendet, weil ich den ganzen Chromecast-Gedöns nicht haben wollte.
Ich könnte wetten, die ganzen Videos sind ziemlich ähnlich vom Inhalt her.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass es mehr Residus gibt.
Das ist viel zu wenig, wenn man nach Corona und Residus dachte, das ist YouTube komplett voll.
Schocking Interview about Corona Virus.
Supermarkt-Mitarbeiter-Packt-Aus.
Schicken wir mal einen Link.
Hast du schon mal Opera GX angeschaut?
Ja, haben wir schon mal angeschaut.
Können die nichts anderes mehr außer Klopapierwitze machen?
Das ist langweilig. Das ist nicht so gut.
Das andere war lustiger.
Der gefällt mir nicht.
Das beste Corona-Meme, was ich in letzter Zeit gesehen hab.
Wartet mal.
Kann man das vollscreenen machen?
Den Sound brauchen wir nicht.
Ich finde es lustig.
Italien fährt hinter China her und ist gerade bei China zu überholen.